today we're going to be speaking with
emily bradleeb who is a clinical
professor of law and faculty director
for harvard law school's food law and
policy clinic um it's so great having
you on today emily really appreciate it
thanks so much i'm so glad to be here so
i mean let's just start with a little
history many of us are familiar with
with food labels in general and also
expiration dates best buy sell buy etc
what's the sort of history of that when
did it start why did it start
so we see um kind of this modern
landscape of you know these labels on
most food products really taking shape
in the 70s and at that time it was
really um consumers were pushing
companies and saying that they wanted to
know about the freshness of their
products and so you know if you think
about where we were at that time it was
sort of
starting after like post-world war ii
people are getting more
you know further away from where their
food is produced buying more things in
the grocery store and you know people
said if i'm not part of the farm and
getting it directly from a farm how will
i know how fresh it is right
and that's when we we saw a lot of
activity in terms of um voluntary use of
these labels on the part of companies
now there was also in that period of
time in like the 20 years preceding the
70s there was a move away from most of
the things at the grocery store our
ingredients to
really like the food product right
something that that's manufactured and
scent that and
is that also part of why we started to
see those markings that like with a
banana by looking at it you can mostly
tell what is the status of this banana
whereas with some of these products it
might be less clear yeah that's totally
right so
you know and i think even today in you
know
fast forward to now where there's
there's labels on lots of products a lot
of states require them but it's
primarily on packaged foods because i
think there's a sense that um you know
banana an apple you know a food a food
that you can pick up and hold and that's
sort of in its raw form uh that people
can really make their own judgments
about how fresh it is and how spoiled
how close it is to being spoiled um and
it's really packaged foods that you see
these labels on because people don't
really know they they can't open it up
in the store and smell it and waste it
so um
there's best if used by
there's sell by
there's a straight up expiration date
that sometimes is there
these things presumably mean different
things right
one would think actually that's one of
the biggest issues is that consumers
sort of look at them and think these
labels must be telling me different
things but in fact um
you know most there's no law that really
regulates what those different terms
mean there's no
um
you know there's no law defining cell by
as compared to used by or expires on
right now
in fact there's no federal law
regulating date labels at all so the
federal government with the very small
exception of infant formula has not
required anything and then in the states
that have requirements they use them
very interchangeably and so i think
that's one of the places where we got
really interested because consumers are
misled like they they think that they're
you know that they're seeing two
different labels and that they mean
something different but there's not
there's not any evidence that that's the
case right so so i mean if i see
as the common man if i see
sell by it suggests to me it should be
sold by that date but it's still pretty
good for some period of time beyond that
best if used by says it it should to me
it should be consumed by that day but
you're saying it's not actually there's
not actually an infrastructure that
guarantees that that's what i'm being
told
yeah that's totally right and you know
as we talk about why how this can be
fixed i do think there is a piece of
drawing on what consumers think that
they're reading yeah and you know
reducing the number of labels and really
drawing on like what consumers already
are understanding but just making that
the case so that consumers aren't you
know aren't being confused about it
with something like um i mean when i
first really started thinking about the
value of some of these labels is when i
saw for example an expiration date on
salt
and you know when we think about salt
it's like salt's been around for
millions of years it's just sort of
naturally occurring what does it mean if
salt expires um
does that have any meaning at all why
does salt expire right i agree with your
same vinegar similarly it's already
turned vinegar now it is vinegar it's
not going into some other thing
um bottled water you know and i think
people are trying to like deal with this
cognitive dissonance by making up some
reason that the label so i hear people
say a lot oh the label on bottled water
is like when the plastic is going to
leach into the water i mean that is
there's no that is not happening or if
it is the date is not the date of which
that happens um you know i think you're
right that there are a lot of food
products that um
it doesn't it doesn't seem very clear
why a label a date label would be needed
on them except that consumers have just
come to
expect them on so many products and you
know i've actually talked to people who
have said when i pick something up at
the store that doesn't have a date label
on it i'm not sure what to do
um so you know again i think um
uh in some of our early work we thought
well maybe we should just remove the
label on foods where it's really
meaningless um and i think that gets a
lot of uh we got a lot of pushback from
consumer groups on that so we're really
thinking how can we take what we have
and make it work better and make it a
line better and be less misleading um
you know knowing that in some cases we
are where we are and we can't kind of
completely overhaul the system
the um if we want to apply like a
corporate profit motive to this
one could imagine
you could have foods that are safe for
much longer than the dates say
but maybe the manufacturer is worried
there could be reputational damage
because it might not taste quite as good
or whatever the case may be how much of
that is a factor in these labels
yeah
i mean that is it's a really big factor
especially you know if you think about
where we are right now which is some
states require dates on certain foods
there's a quite a just you know huge
variation in what foods states require
labels on and then what you can do after
the label um so that leaves a lot up to
the manufacturer as far as like what
words to use the science but or if there
is any science behind how they're
setting that date um and of course for
companies they want you to eat their
food when it's going to taste the best
right so more even more cynical version
that people say a lot is you know is it
that they just want you to throw it away
and buy more and i don't think there's
necessarily evidence of that but there
is evidence and companies would say this
outright that
you know they want to set a label when
their product they think will taste the
best and they want to leave some wiggle
room for the fact that you might not put
your yogurt in the refrigerator right
away and that you know so they're kind
of being conservative even in that date
that they're setting
when it comes to um
food waste you know we've talked for so
long on this program about you got a
portion of food that is just wasted on
the field so to speak it already is sort
of like by the time it would get to the
supermarket it might not look so good so
you lose some there you lose food due to
spoilage and you lose food due to
expiration dates and a question that's
often asked is shouldn't that all be
donated somewhere and one of the reasons
that sometimes given for why it's not is
if you donate stuff to a food pantry
beyond the expiration date one are you
sending the message that people who need
to go to a food pantry are deserving of
expired food right in sort of like the
pr issue with that but also the concern
of if someone gets sick and it's beyond
an expiration date is the donor
potentially legally liable so are those
and are there other ways in which this
is actually preventing dealing with an
issue like hunger yeah yeah i think
you're you're spot on um
so
um i would say as far as the first point
this sort of stigma point about is this
bad food are we essentially saying like
we're gonna give bad food to people
um you know that are that are accepting
donated food on that piece
what our approach has been is to say
um if you really standardize the labels
to have one label that's really clearly
about food the small handful of foods
that actually increase in risk after the
date then everyone can be clear in their
own households and then we wouldn't
donate those foods we're not we
shouldn't be donating anything that
actually is riskier after the date
and then if you have a separate standard
label that's really telling people for
all of these foods you can keep eating
it as long as it smells okay tastes okay
you know this is just totally an
estimate of freshness
and then i would say i mean those should
be able to be sold they should be able
to be donated people should feel free to
use them people should swap them
whatever it is and so i think you know
to me a law that says that they only can
be donated but not sold
and would you know wouldn't make sense
because it would increase that stigma
and i'll say one you know pure country
that's done a really nice job of this is
the uk where they have
used by is the standard label on food
that becomes
riskier after the date
best before is the standard label on
food that is labeled just for freshness
and then they've done actual campaigns
with consumers they had one last earlier
this year that was um
like look smell taste don't waste and
the whole campaign was really to let
people know if you see best before
labels on it there's no way that there's
no scientific way to make those accurate
and there's no risk after the date it's
really just about your preference and
your power
um and again and then they make it very
clear those could be donated they can be
sold at a discount you can still eat
them you can still serve them no one's
gonna get sick
and so i think again there's there's
like a very clear roadmap for how we
could improve on this and and in a way
that makes it not just for um
you know for for donation and giveaway
but also for everyone to save dollars
there's a whole other kind of category
of food labels
these include
certified organic
all natural
no preservatives no added sugar
whole grains only you know we can kind
of go down the list and and different
ones mean different things are any of
these other than organic actually
regulated terms in any way that have a
set meaning every time they are used
so
it's a hard question because there's
truly so many of those labels yeah
our as like what so does so to speak eco
labels like organic that really relate
to like the
the way that they're grown and produced
in the environmental side organic is the
only one and there was legislation
passed around
bioengineered label which would be foods
that are genetically modified and be
labeled that will also be regulated
on the health side
there are some that are that are
regulated for example if you want to say
that a food is healthy oh
right
or some but there are also a lot that
aren't that heavily regulated so on that
side it sort of depends on the label um
but i should say you know
uh
these a lot of those fall to the food
and drug administration to enforce and
like there's thousands and thousands of
products with thousands and thousands of
labels and i think um i think most
people in this space present party
included would say that you know there
might be labels on there that aren't
actually being enforced because fda just
doesn't have the capacity to get to all
of them and make sure
at one point there was this heart
healthy label which many of us would be
familiar from oats quaker oats
but it was basically if i recall
correctly at least in its initial
version based on the amount of fat and
so you had
very strange products including at one
point i think it was like the equivalent
of some kind of fruit roll-up type candy
which i think qualified for the label
based on its absence of fat but it's not
really something that we would think i
mean it's a highly processed it's candy
essentially and so it was like this what
does this really mean right
right right no i think you're right and
i think this has been a critique of a
lot of those labels healthy
you know heart healthy low fat whatever
um
there are disqualifying levels of other
nutrients but sugar
which really people weren't as worried
about
you know in the 80s when a lot of these
labeling and early 90s so now you have
these bizarre outcomes where there's
like no disqualifying level of sugar for
all of these health related claims um
you know i think this is something that
fda has been supposedly working on
hopefully we'll you know get around to
really updating some of those labels
because i think they are really
misleading for consumers and i think
today sugar is really one of the most
concerning ingredients and products in
terms of just
the you know where we are as a country
so what are on sugar labeling like what
are some of the issues it seems i mean
some that come to me off the top of my
head is sometimes it will say no sugar
but it has various syrups which
are you know arguably not different than
sugar from a health standpoint
sometimes you will see um things like
sweetened with beet sugar as if that's
really different than cane sugar or
regular sugar when it's unclear there
really is a difference right i mean it
seems sort of like
the the gluten-free label on an apple
where it's like yes it's gluten-free but
is that really actionable and relevant
in any way
yes totally agree um yeah evaporated
cane
evaporated cane syrup is one you will
see and i still see it and i think you
know fda said it's not allowed again
they don't have the capacity to enforce
all of them so consumers pay the price
of that um you know i think that there's
both uh responsibility on the part of
the fda
and potentially on congress to really
beef up the the
resources so that those can be enforced
um evaporated cane syrup is literally
sugar it is what everyone would think of
as sugar and yet you know again it will
say no sugar and it will have that on a
product and
yeah uh two other specific ones that i
want to ask about um so use organic is
actually a regulated term with a
specific meaning about about the the how
it's grown or whatever um when it comes
to all natural what is important for
people to understand about whether all
natural has any meaning whatsoever
great question um no one can answer that
question because there's no definition
um really from the food and drug
administration for all natural so
there's been a huge huge amount of
litigation um particularly in california
which has really nice um
laws that are very supportive towards
consumers just a lot of litigation
around a product with an all-natural
claim um you know and then plaintiffs
consumers saying that they bought the
product and then realized afterwards
there were certain processing elements
or was ultra processed or included you
know gene edited or you know genetically
engineered materials that people would
think don't seem natural
and you know there's there's i would say
for now i treat that claim as if like i
just ignore it completely i would say
like that mean that is meaningless at
the moment um and i think again there's
there's a big question mark as to
um if and when we will we will see the
fda come out with a real definition that
can give consumers a little more
confidence in that claim
last thing i want to ask about and i
know we're now getting like a couple
levels removed from from where we
started
homeopathic products
herbal products some supplements etc
where they say
statements have not been evaluated by
the fda
etc we've all seen that type of thing
um what are the concerns and sort of
what is in that general space that
consumers should be aware of when
looking at those products
yeah now you're a couple steps from my
bellywick um
they're they're even you know i've
already said already that there's a lot
of claims on foods that um either fda
hasn't yet defined like natural they
don't really have a great definition um
or where there is a very clear
definition but they just don't have the
resources to enforce
once you get into supplements um you
know herbal things etc
it's even more so that way i mean a lot
of people in the food space will call
that really the wild west in terms of
the
um
in terms of the the level of both laws
and enforcement
um so i think it's it's a really
difficult area i think there's a lot of
folks calling for more regulation there
and
you know making sure both that
there's really two concerns one is when
you buy a supplement is what's in there
actually what it says it is right and
the second is are the claims about what
it can do for your health validated in
any way and i think on both ends of that
it's a really big question mark and it's
hard for the companies that are you know
trying to do it well and and trying to
do a good job because i think they will
probably like more enforcement so that
they you know they're they're that
people will have more trust in that
space yeah with without a doubt um emily
broadley is a clinical professor of law
and faculty director for harvard law
school's food law and policy clinic
really appreciate your time today
great talking to you thanks